bonsoir et bienvenue à vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir est
journaliste au Point et elle a décidé
vingt ans après la mort de Marie
Trintignant de rouffrir le dossier de la
faire canta bonsoir Anne-Sophie Yann
bonsoir et merci d'être là votre livre
désire noire chez Flammarion à porte de
nouveaux éclairages et ils sont
terrifiants c'est l'histoire d'un clan
qui va céder à la paranoïa pour sauver
son chef et le regard aujourd'hui à
l'heure du MiTo sur les faits et bien
son glaçant on va y revenir en longueur
tout à l'heure mais on commence avec
notre grand débat 12e journée d'action
contre la réforme des retraites et ça
n'est pas la dernière très bien déjà
elle a ses CGT quand la CFDT est un peu
plus prudente ce soir moins de grévistes
moins de monde dans les cortèges mais la
pression est toujours très forte à la
veille d'une décision très très attendue
du Conseil constitutionnel demain soir
l'unité syndicale va-t-elle tenir grand
débat dans un instant avec nos invités
sur ce plateau avant de retrouver à 20
h15 les parties pris de nos affranchis
et puis Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu ce
soir vous me suivez Anne Sofia avec
plaisir ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
serait-ce la dernière manifestation de
Laurent Berger contre la réforme des
retraites rien n'est moins sûr alors où
tout le monde retient son souffle avant
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
demain soir on va s'interroger sur
l'avenir du mouvement social il va
certainement prendre de nouvelles formes
un million de personnes selon la CGT
dans le pays 380
000 selon la police et des manifestants
déterminés à s'organiser pour tenir
bonsoir Erwan balano bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes député MoDem du
Finistère vous débattez ce soir avec
Adrien Clouet bonsoir député la France
insoumise de Haute-Garonne vous avez
battu le pavé j'imagine aujourd'hui tout
le monde n'a pas vu aujourd'hui bien sûr
en tout cas Céline Verzeletti était dans
les cortèges bonsoir vous êtes
secrétaire confédéral de la CGT enfin
bonsoir Jean-François Amadieu vous êtes
sociologue spécialiste des mouvements
sociaux Anne-Sophie Yann journaliste
citoyenne forcément vous avez un petit
avis sur ce mouvement social n'hésitez
pas à intervenir quand vous le souhaitez
on commence par PL anter le décor avec
le billet de Stéphane bakowski elle est
déclarations des syndicats les chiffres
et les images tout ça en 200 secondes
rendez-vous compte le chrono de Blacko
c'est parti
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir faire ses fans bonsoir
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors cette journée alors bon vous
voudrez faire une chronique vous savez
que pour faire une chronique Lidl ça va
avoir une bonne accroche une image qui
capte l'attention de son public alors
badaboum voilà mon accroche vous avez
reconnu ou pas oui oui c'est le naufrage
du Titanic dire que ce matin c'est
Laurent Berger qui faisait remarqué ça
que demain nous serons le 111e
anniversaire du naufrage du Titanic qui
a sombré le 14 avril 2012 donc la
question si on veut filer un peu l'image
c'est en cas après la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel qui va sombrer
est-ce que c'est le gouvernement ou
est-ce que c'est l'Inter syndicat donc
évidemment si le Conseil
constitut comme on dit maintenant
censure l'article sur le reportage
c'est évidemment là peut-être que le
président Macron sera sur une chaloupe
mais président de chaloupe ou président
de paquebot c'est pas exactement la même
chose en revanche si le conseil ne
censure pas le rapport de l'âge de la
retraite et que bien le président
promulg là il peut y avoir une voix
d'eau dans le bateau de l'interstradical
ce qui me restait unique d'un côté la
CGT ce matin c'est ce féminin maintenant
la nouvelle secrétaire général
Ivry pour soutenir les éboueurs qui
veulent transformer Paris en décharge si
on en retire pas le projet de loi de
réforme vous allez voir que il y a pas
besoin d'avoir une moustache pour croire
dans le rapport de force on l'écoute non
c'est pas le dernier jour ça je vous le
confirme on va se revoir encore beaucoup
et vous allez venir encore beaucoup sur
des journées de mobilisation donc c'est
certainement pas le dernier jour puisque
sauf si Emmanuel Macron ce soir retire
la réforme des retraites là auquel cas
ce sera le dernier jour et demain on
vous invitera pour une grande fête alors
évidemment comme cette semaine sur Sci
on a entendu Laurent Berger qui disait
on va pas manifester pendant 6 mois si
la loi est promulgaire pourrait penser
qu'ils ne sont pas sur la même longueur
mais c'est pas si évident donc qu'est-ce
qu'elle dit la CGT elle dit retrait de
la réforme
non promulgation de la réforme vous
pouvez m'expliquer la différence
a l'air très motivé pour manifester le
premier mais il y a un autre point
malgré tout qui pourrait faire un trou
dans la coque c'est toujours pareil de
la personnalité c'est si l'attitude à
adopter face à l'invitation du président
de la République qui voudrait tourner la
page des retraites et parler d'autre
chose donc côté CGT voici la réaction je
vous la montre parce qu'on a un grand
écran donc quand on mettre une image
c'est vraiment ce qu'elle a dit ce matin
ce film bien il a dit alors là c'est
invitation j'ai envie de dire lol donc
mort de rire donc on sait bien que côté
CFDT on laisse pas la chaise vide on est
toujours prêt à négocier bon ça c'est
Laurent Berger mais il est quand même
pas pressé de négocier le renverger
c'est-à-dire que si le président pense
tourner la page
on va pas passer à autre chose faut pas
croire que les gens allaient
travailleurs et travailleuses qui se
mobilisent et qui sont contre cette
réforme depuis des mois vont passer
comme ça à autre chose ça ne marche pas
c'est pas comme ça que ce traite les
citoyens et les citoyens et notamment le
monde du travail donc quand il y aura un
délai de naissance je le dis très
clairement alors attention Myriam le
Conseil constitut ne prend pas une
décision demain il en prend deux oui
parce qu'il pourrait autoriser leur
référence
sur cette question de réforme alors du
coup ça changerait la forme de la
mobilisation forcément puisque ça serait
plus la rue contre le Parlement
puisqu'on on repasserait par les urnes
donc là dès qu'on passe par les urnes
bah faut regarder les fondages regardez
depuis 3 mois de mobilisation qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé Laurent Berger a gagné
20 points de popularité je vous laisse
regarder les intermédiaires et en bas le
président Macron je me baisse a perdu 10
points de personnalité donc si ça se
finit au référendum cette histoire de
réforme des retraites moi quand je
regarde les sondages je dirais que
Laurent Berger par favori mais après il
y a des alors il y a beaucoup de
d'étapes avant d'arriver un éventuel
référendum on va en parler avant de vous
demander ce que vous ferez si le Conseil
valide partiellement globalement
revenons sur cette journée Céline
Verzeletti bon il y a moins de monde ça
c'est un fait il y a moins de monde dans
les cortège il y a moins de grévistes
dans les transports dans l'éducation
nationale c'est encore un critère pour
vous vous y voyez un essoufflement ou ça
y est on est dans autre chose et ça fait
déjà 12 fois 12 manifestations c'est
déjà un record alors oui déjà c'était un
record en effet vous le dites et vous
avez raison c'est une deuxième journée
sachant qu'il y a aussi des salariés qui
sont en reconductible donc qui sont sur
beaucoup beaucoup de journées de grève
ça coûte cher pas la journée la journée
où il y a le moins de participants et de
participants quand même puisque il y a
eu aussi alors je sais plus quelle
journée exactement
on le sait que sur un temps aussi long
on ne peut pas les mobilisation ne sont
jamais
linéaire c'est-à-dire que il y a des
piques il y a il y a des moments un peu
moins importants quoi qu'il en soit pour
une douzième journée nous on
comptabilise je sais pas comment vous
combien vous avez dit mais nous là selon
la CGT alors voilà la CGT puisqu'on
n'avait pas tous les mêmes à un million
300000 là maintenant on a quasi tous les
chiffres puisqu'on a au fur et à mesure
les chiffres qui remontent des
différentes villes parce que ça continue
c'est quand même une mobilisation qui
qui est très ancrée au niveau des
différentes villes que ce soit les
petites et moyennes villes ça c'est très
important et on le voit la motivation
est toujours là donc un million 300000
au bout de donc c'est la 12e journée
c'est quand même énorme et inédit donc
voilà l'envie d'y aller de gagner ce
retrait il est toujours là l'énergie et
la colère est toujours aussi importante
c'est très clair il y a des journées
d'action demain oui oui alors ça on
aimerait comprendre des rassemblements
quoi devant le Conseil constitutionnel
on sent que beaucoup de pression autour
de 17h
c'est une journée importante on l'a dit
aujourd'hui c'était une journée de
mobilisation demain ça allait encore
d'ailleurs c'est à l'appel aussi de
l'intersyndicale c'est de 31 points de
manifestation à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale ce soir ensemble unis
CFDT CGT l'appelle la dernière fois
lorsqu'il y a eu un communiqué de
l'intersonica il a appelé au 13 et au 14
aussi sur sous différentes formes donc
différentes initiatives qui elles sont
décidées au niveau des différentes
villes et des différentes territoires
donc à Paris rassemblement aussi je
crois que c'est à l'hôtel de ville et
surtout que les villes parce que bien
évidemment d'une part en continu donc à
réclamer ce retrait ou cette non
promulgation de toute manière c'est
c'est la même chose et aussi c'est vrai
qu'il y a quand même une petite attente
du côté du Conseil constitutionnel on va
en parler voilà mais avant de donner la
parole aux élus je veux bien comprendre
comment on peut qualifier cette douzième
journée Jean-François on est dans un
moment d'attente il y a une pression qui
est très forte ça c'est sûr il y a
encore des casseurs en fin de cortège on
l'a vu à Bastille quelle analyse vous
faites de ce mouvement qui ne au fond
qui ne faiblit pas mais qui forcément
parce que ça coûte cher c'est souffle
aussi dans une journée je dirais qui n'a
pas il y a pas de surprise
les organisations syndicales comme tout
le monde ça va être très bien que on ne
fait pas un nombre très important de
journées avec des taux de participation
aussi élevés la partie passion au grève
forcément on sait aussi que les gens
s'épuisent c'est tout à fait logique
donc sans surprise le les débordements
les violences si on regarde à Paris dans
les villes ailleurs en France
des interpellations en fin de cortège on
attend les chiffres manifestants
à l'occasion d'autres journées pas
particulièrement aujourd'hui donc c'est
plutôt attendu
faire un peu de peine Céline Verzeletti
mais c'est vrai incontestablement un
mouvement ne peut pas durer
éternellement sous cette forme bon donc
les organisations classiques syndicales
et classiquement
euh bien sûr il y aura le 1er mai ne
l'oublions pas il y a encore une journée
et une journée syndicale le premier mais
c'est pareil
le souvenir peut-être que c'est qui le
sait j'ai essayé de me souvenir moi il
faut que je regarde dans mes fiches de
quand date la dernière grande journée où
toutes les secrétaires généraux
d'organisation et toutes les
organisations étaient ensemble car il
faut quand même savoir que
depuis des années plusieurs d'entre
elles enfin elle faisait exprès de ne
pas être ensemble et surtout pas dans le
grand défilé parisien ça ça n'arrivait
jamais donc c'était délibéré sa
témoignait de bon mais bien sûr des
divisions syndicales qu'on connaît bien
en France mais là c'est un signal assez
incroyable oui pour dans l'histoire des
syndicats et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
que je note ce que disait Céline
verzility les termes sont les mêmes
retraits ou par retrait ou c'est tout ça
on joue un peu sur les mots on fait
jouer les nuances mais je suis frappé
par le fait que finalement y compris
quand on interroge les gens sur le
terrain c'est c'est on se réfère
beaucoup à l'Inter syndical tout ça doit
être décidé ensemble il faut que ça
tienne et il y a une telle volonté que
ça tienne que oui qu'on peut même penser
que dans ce qui va se passer maintenant
ça va encore tenir un certain temps
alors Erwan Malan le mouvement on va
dire entre entre deux eaux en pleine
attente avant la décision du Conseil
Constitution il y a une chose qui qui
change pas c'est l'opinion qui lâche pas
je vous propose d'écouter Frédéric David
lefe il était ce matin sur France Inter
et vous réagissez juste après
je trouve que la situation est tout à
fait figée figée à au regard du rejet de
cette réforme qui est massif en gros
deux tiers des Français et trois quarts
des salariés des personnes concernées et
puis reste massif ça c'est complètement
enraciné et puis 12e journée la
lassitude est là il y a moins de monde
dans les rues on le sait et pour autant
le soutien au moment social atteint 62%
c'est 11 points de plus que ce qui était
le 13 janvier à la veille de la
présentation du projet de loi par Madame
borne et la première journée et
symboliquement 62% c'est exactement le
chiffre mesuré par l'ifope des gens en
95 au moment de la Réforme Juppé tout se
passe comme si voilà le temps ne
changeait rien à l'affaire si je puis
dire ça doit vous interpeller ça quand
même vous avez parié sur la division de
l'opinion et elle est toujours là moi
non parce que j'ai toujours considéré
que
les manifestants quand ils font ça dans
dans le calme et comme ça a été la
plupart débutant dans les manifestations
sont complètement légitimes après ça
m'étonne pas non plus que et je crois
que ça a été bien expliqué que que la
baisse des fin qui est moins de
manifestants et des cortèges moins
importants des Français 11 points de
plus que le 12 janvier à la veille de la
présentation de la réforme et on doit en
prendre comment
nous le groupe démocrate on demande que
qui on a on a saisi la main de Laurent
Berger sur la question d'une médiation
et sur la question de remettre un
certain nombre d'éléments sur la table
personnellement et le groupe démocrate
on pense que dans le texte tel qu'il est
vu qu'il y a cette fameuse clause de
revoyure dont on ne parle pas il y a
beaucoup de Français qui qui ont
peut-être oublié que c'est pas demain 64
ans l'âge de départ à la retraite c'est
progressif effectivement c'est septembre
pour ceux qui devaient partir ces trois
mois de plus et cet impactant et il faut
en prendre compte c'est évident mais
c'est progressif et en 2027 on sera à 63
ans
bon donc ça nous laisse quand même le
temps de mettre un certain nombre
d'éléments sur la table de travailler
sur les pénibilités ce travail sur les
carrières longues ou continuer à
travailler sur l'emploi des seniors il y
a des pistes il y a des travails de
remettre sur la table ce que vous nous
dites c'est que 63 ans 64 ans c'est pas
une fatalité en 2027 tout peut être
renégocié c'est ce que notre élément
politique c'est pas ce que je vous ai
dit ce que je vous ai dit c'est que il y
a des moyens
c'est de se dire que il y a des
possibilités si on trouve des moyens de
financement si on trouve un équilibre de
ce régime de peut-être rester à 63 ans
c'est pas pour autre chose qu'on l'a
fait bon voilà en tout cas côté modem le
parti de François Bayrou fait des gestes
d'ouverture à ce stade du rapport de
force Adrien Clouet vous étiez dans le
cortège on va écouter un reportage dans
un instant sur l'état d'esprit des
manifestants aujourd'hui il va y avoir
des journées d'action y compris pendant
que le Conseil constitutionnel va
travailler demain on qu'ils ont déjà
bien planché mais c'est quand même une
journée importante vous vous soutenez
vous la France insoumise ces journées
d'action comme ça pour mettre la
pression sur les sages au moment même où
ils vont rendre leur avis c'est pas sur
les sages c'est sur la macronie dans son
ensemble parce qu'on entend bien que là
c'est sauf qu'il peut c'est à dire les
mêmes qui soutenaient en janvier février
mordicus l'idée qu'on allait mettre deux
enfermes à tout le monde sont en train
de nous expliquer que finalement et
c'est pas des cours des voix de sortie
des manières différentes de faire c'est
très bien on aurait pu en débattre plus
de 11 jours à l'Assemblée parce qu'il y
a beaucoup d'idées sur ce domaine là
donc on voit bien que finalement tout le
monde lâche le projet il y a plus grand
monde qui le soutient il reste madame
borne en tout cas pour les jours qui lui
reste dans comme première ministre il y
a Monsieur Macron évidemment entre deux
voyages à l'étranger qui trouvent
parfois cinq minutes pour engueuler ses
conseillers
et un gouvernement il y a un président
il y a des institutions
éventuelle restons quand même
des personnes ils sont hostiles donc non
je l'affirme aujourd'hui dans ce pays
les Français il y a une infime profiter
de personnes qui défend mais oui mais si
on est en démocratie le référentiel
n'est pas que le Président de la
République ses amis ses soutiens le
référentiel c'est la population et le
principe d'un démocrate et je pense
qu'on est d'accord le principe de notre
démocrate c'est de représenter les
électeurs électrices or les électeurs
électriques n'ont pas été amené aux
urnes nous en étant interrogé sur ce
dossier là et ce serait très intéressant
d'ailleurs qu'on le fasse parce qu'on
pourrait trancher définitivement on a
aujourd'hui une crise politique une
crise c'est lorsque des représentants se
retrouvent en décalage pour la majorité
d'entre eux avec les personnes qui
lesquelles doivent représenter il y a
dans ce cas là il y a plusieurs manières
de faire on dit sous l'assemblée on fait
une nouvelle élections on fait un
référendum on suspend on retire on
annule le projet bref on peut s'en
sortir visiblement aujourd'hui il y a
une personne qui s'est enfermée à
l'Élysée et qui veut gouverner seul
contre tout le monde juste vous
apprendre réponse quand même parce que
c'est important la démocratie c'est
c'est aussi
le choix d'un certain nombre de
personnes des députés à un moment donné
sur un programme et sur une
responsabilité et moi la responsabilité
que j'ai en tant que démocrate en tant
que député de notre pays c'est de faire
en sorte que le régime para répartition
continue à vivre moi l'équation elle est
simple il y a une équation simple c'est
pas de baisse des pensions pas de hausse
d'impôts
comment on fait alors
Adrien Clouet c'était la moitié de vos
amendements était pour créer des impôts
pour les financer ce régime donc vous
allez vous mettez maintenant vous
admettez maintenant qu'il y a un
déséquilibre si vous voulez 13 milliards
vous admettez maintenant qu'il y avait
un déséquilibre ah ben il y en a pas
maintenant
vous nous dites largement
des semaines normalement c'était pas
assez long vous voyez
toutes nos propositions dans la tête les
plus déterminées à continuer le
mouvement c'est Clément pervaud qui a
promené son micro d'un cortège à Paris
reportage
sont sur total du texte y plus ni moins
voilà la décision qu'attendent pour
demain les manifestants pour eux il
existe de vrais arguments pour que le
Conseil constitutionnel retoque la
réforme des retraites moi je pense qu'il
y a toutes les raisons évidemment pour
dire que c'est pas Constitution alors
parce que l'utilisation même du 47 1
c'est un dévoiement de la Constitution
parce que il y a pas lieu de faire une
une loi de rectificative de finances en
janvier alors que la loi a été votée en
décembre l'esprit de la Constitution
c'est quand même de pouvoir aussi
laisser la place à l'expression
populaire c'est pas de censurer
l'expression qui sait que qui est dans
la rue et qui a aussi été porté à
l'Assemblée nationale par des
parlementaires mais au-delà des
arguments dans les cortèges la méfiance
règne le Conseil constitutionnel est
loin d'inspirer une confiance illimitée
quand même il y a aussi une dimension
politique est-ce que quelqu'un comme
Alain Juppé va remettre en question des
choses qu'il a lui-même utilisé elles
sont tous pour Macron
vous avez fabu vous avez Juppé tous des
macronistes
donc il y a aucun débat la décision est
déjà prise pour sa constitutionnel dira
peut-être qu'il y a une virgule qui va
pas dans le texte qui est proposé par le
gouvernement le gouvernement leur
proposera plus tard donc non c'est pas
sur le Conseil constitutionnel qu'on
compte quand on veut changer les choses
et rendre le monde plus juste
de nouveau rassemblements sont attendus
au moment de la décision des sages en
cas de validation du texte la rue
pourrait bien se faire entendre comme
dans la foulée du 49-3
alors
on les entend il ne pense qu'à la
décision de demain dès 9 sages rue de
Montpensier rarement une décision ratée
aussi attendue et on entend déjà des
soupçons des inquiétudes sur une
décision qui serait politique qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez leur dire pour les
rassurer ce sont des sages endroits
parce qu'il y a quand même des anciens
premiers ministres le grand Fabius Alain
Juppé des ministres aussi qui sont dans
ces ministres qui sont nommés par le
président lui-même madame Gouraud
monsieur Mezard et d'autres c'est vrai
que cette question là c'est sûr qu'elle
soit la décision elle va être soulevée
on peut pas mettre d'un côté on peut pas
mettre de la pression sur le Conseil
constitutionnel
et lui reprocher qui serait politique
enfin le Conseil constitutionnel est un
organe et l'organe suprême de notre
Constitution c'est lui qui vise ou
invalide les processus constitutionnels
il se base sur le fond ensuite il y a
toujours et là je vous l'accorde quand
on fait du droit il y a toujours une
interprétation politique mais on ne peut
pas leur mettre la pression et leur et
dire qui serait légitime parce qu'ils
Invalides
et notamment la dangereux parce que ça
veut dire que ça veut dire que on
considère que le Conseil constitutionnel
ne sert plus à rien les conseils
constitutionnel il va dire oui non il va
dire un certain nombre de choses il va
retoquer une partie peut-être peut-être
pas peut-être l'ensemble du texte moi
j'avoue que je suis commissaire aux lois
je connais bien notre Constitution je
suis dans l'incapacité aujourd'hui de
vous dire est-ce que exactement ce qui
va décider j'ai une intuition sur un
certain nombre de sujets je pense qu'il
va valider le texte avec en retoquant et
en retoquant certains dispositifs et
aussi en mettant des réserves de
d'interprétation qui sont là pour le
coup extrêmement
la constitutionnalité de la loi là on va
rentrer dans une petite séquence un peu
prospective et donc hypothétique Adrien
Clouet si effectivement selon
l'intuition nawan balano le Conseil
constitutionnel ne fait pas une censure
globale mais partielle en invalidant les
cavaliers législatives mais en
consacrant en validant l'article 7 sur
le reportage est-ce que vous vous êtes
député de la nation vous reconnaîtrez
cette décision
attention j'ai pas le choix mais la
question est pas là la question est pas
là on a un texte qui est politiquement
et légitime à mes yeux dès lors comment
on fait pour le faire tomber le Conseil
constitutionnels
j'ai pas l'imprimé et le mettre chez moi
au-dessus dans le salon c'est sûr ça
veut dire mais la question est pas là la
question elle est politique la question
elle est est-ce que on est capable
aujourd'hui de compter sur ce conseil
pour protéger une certaine vision la
démocratie en France et c'est un débat
et le Conseil demain et amené à prendre
une décision qui est inédite c'est pour
ça que c'est compliqué d'avoir une
intuition parce que jamais on a eu ce
type de texte utilisé pour une réforme
pareil et avec un cumul conjoint de
toutes les procédures de contraintes du
Parlement donc la situation est
inéditeur
et donc moi j'espère que ça
jurisprudence fasse tomber le texte si
jamais il fait tomber qu'un petit bout
c'est ça de prix et ben on marchera pour
faire tomber pour vous on marchera c'est
à dire on continuera à appeler à
manifester
le conseil ne fait pas la loi il dit si
elle est conforme à la Constitution
qu'elle le soit ou non moi je souhaite
son retrait qu'elle tombe si elle peut
tomber demain c'est du temps de gagner
s'il faut encore avoir quelques semaines
de lutte et ben on luttera donc
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est presque 95
ou presque non on le CPE c'est
l'université ça serait quoi une loi
promulguée qui serait pas appliquée
jusqu'au retrait c'est ça votre alors
stratégie il y a eu différents propos
dire il y a plusieurs étapes on a
demandé le retrait à partir du moment où
si donc c'est validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel le gouvernement il a
plusieurs solutions il peut se
précipiter à promulguer la loi le
président voilà donc le président de la
République quand le mois qui donc voilà
et si ce précipite je trouve que c'est
un mauvais signal mais comme jusqu'à
présent ne fait que des faux pas je
pense que c'est ce qui risque
malheureusement de se passer donc ça
attisera un peu plus la colère mais donc
s'il se précipite à Prom cette loi nous
nous demanderons la non-application de
cette loi promulguée et comment
concrètement concrètement se mobilisant
c'est ce qui s'est passé
elle n'a pas été appliquée parce que
justement les mobilisations ont continué
ils étaient particulièrement massives et
nous on compte bien évidemment alors sur
différentes mobilisations on l'a dit il
y a des grèves alors il y a des grèves
certaines reconductibles d'autre part il
y a un nouveau des secteurs
professionnels qui qui ont arrêté à un
moment donné la grève et qui s'y
remettent vous avez parlé des éboueurs
de Paris par exemple il y a aussi au
niveau des raffineries des blocages
c'est important aller au blocage sur
l'économie il y aura des blocages et ce
que je dis moi je le redis et vous
l'avez vu tous les reportages le
montrent la population tous ceux et
celles qui sont en mobilisation
aujourd'hui sont très déterminées et ils
ont raison parce que pour le coup cette
réforme ça a été dit elle illégitime
quoi qu'il en soit il est éligible
socialement politiquement et je dirais
que le gouvernement Emmanuel Macron
n'ont fait que défauts
une légère différence dans le discours
entre entre vous et la CGT et Laurent
Berger à la CFDT qui lui n'est pas
exactement la même chose sur la décision
qu'il respectera et on entend bien qu'il
n'est plus dans une perspective de
journée d'action nationale c'est pas la
question c'est que une loi elle peut
être votée
des mois et des mois pour une loi si
elle est déjà promulguée je sais pas si
il a dit ça exactement quoi qu'il en
soit qu'il y a aujourd'hui il y a une il
y a une inter syndicale il y a une inter
syndicale qui est en cours on va
continuer à discuter de manière unitaire
du processus de mobilisation et de la
suite je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
pour dire quand même que cette loi elle
n'est elle ne sera pas de toute manière
légitime que nous ne voulons pas
travailler plus longtemps ça a été dit
pour différentes raisons que nous avions
tous et tous des propositions de
financement qui n'ont pas été entendus
et pas celle que vous dites parce que
vous vous restreigner soit baisser les
pensions soit augmenter les impôts en
effet les escales par les impôts
sociales aussi les cotisations sociales
mais que vous n'entendez pas et c'est
bien dommage et tout ce que vous avez
dit sur la pénibilité sur l'emploi des
seniors c'était avant qu'il fallait en
discuter parce que nous dire que on vous
fait travailler plus longtemps et après
éventuellement qu'on va discuter de
pénibilité de l'emploi du Seigneur c'est
pas possible c'est pas sérieux et nous
dire que peut-être après on reviendra
sur l'âge de départ non ça non plus et
personne n'éduque c'est pour ça que les
millions de personnes elles se
mobilisent parce que il faut arrêter de
de prendre les gens quand même pour des
imbéciles Jean-François Mathieu toujours
dans cette perspective d'une validation
partielle mais on va dire de la pierre
angulaire valider du texte sur le
reportage l'article 7 vous pensez que
l'unité syndicale peut tenir entre la
CGT et la CFDT ou pas
côté pour pour le moment je vois qu'il y
a beaucoup d'efforts qui sont faits
au-delà de quelques nuances de
vocabulaire vous qu'on a souligné et
beaucoup d'efforts qui sont faits pour
qu'on ne voit pas tout de suite qu'il y
a des stratégies ou des trajectoires
différentes il faut savoir que même pour
la CGT il est classique enfin d'un
mouvement dure pas éternellement et par
conséquent les organisations syndicales
la CGT en tête disent toujours au bout
d'un certain temps que la lutte continue
sous d'autres formes
après et qu'elle ne s'arrêtera pas c'est
traditionnel c'est toujours comme ça
qu'on fait mais ça veut pas dire que ça
traduira concrètement faudra peut-être
pour le CPE quand même juste un point
importants c'était catastrophique les
étudiants étaient
ultra mobilisés toutes choses qu'on ne
voit pas actuellement donc c'est un
contexte qui est très différent j'ajoute
quand même qu'à un autre point il y a
encore des marges de manoeuvre Laurent
Berger suggéré alors tout le monde dit
que c'est impossible le président
refusera d'utiliser l'article 10 et
puisque le compromis au motif que le
compromis politique a été élaboré au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée et on commission
mixte n'est pas équilibré puisqu'il est
déséquilibré par le fait qu'on retira
certaines dispositions donc ça veut dire
que le compromis global déjà social
n'existe pas
politiquement c'est un peu bizarre
puisque ça faisait un tout les
parlementaires ont voté pour un tout
pour un ensemble pas pour un article
seulement on n'a pas voté oui bien sûr
ils ont pas voté
effectivement tout le monde dit que le
président ne tendra pas ne saisirez pas
cette perche que Laurent Berger du temps
j'ajoute qu'il y a une autre possibilité
en 2006 souvenons-nous que il y avait
dans la loi de 2006 égalité des chances
un deuxième texte à part le contrat
purement embauche c'était le CV anonyme
pendant 8 ans aucun décret d'application
n'est jamais sorti et la loi ne s'est
jamais appliquée à la finie par étape
brochet en 2015
mais c'est pour vous dire que il y a
aussi cette possibilité
et après il y a une grosse incertitude
sur le fameux référendum alors le
référendum d'initiative partagé il y a
beaucoup d'obstacles aujourd'hui on a
appris qu'un deuxième recours avec été
déposé pour ce référendum d'initiative
partagée manifestement le premier
n'était pas suffisamment bien ficelé
avec vraiment un gros doute sur sa
constitutionnalité vous personnellement
modem le référendum sur les retraites
est-ce que ce serait pas la bonne sortie
de crise alors moi j'aimerais
j'adore retrouver l'intitulé du
référendum qui règle le conflit
et que effectivement mais vous voyez
bien comment
une fois qu'on a une fois qu'on a dit ça
comment on fait tout le reste du travail
et du financement vous voyez bien que ce
texte sur le texte qui a été débattu
donc dans le format 47-1 donc plfssr
donc
un budget social contraint dans le temps
il y a tout un nombre d'articles pour
régler un tout un tas de questions donc
tous ces questions là tranchées par
référendum c'est compliqué bon une fois
qu'on a dit ça moi je pense que
référendum accepté demain attendez
justement j'y arrive la question la
question pour moi la question
aujourd'hui c'est comment on réconcilie
les Français comment on refait commun
j'ai envie de dire sur cette question
comment on règle des vrais sujets qui
sont soulevés par la CGT par la CFDT par
la CFTC par tous les syndicats sur la
pénibilité les Tantra de travail alors
ça le Président il a ouvert sa porte
c'est nouveau de vous recevoir il y a
Laurent Berger qui parle d'une grande
conférence sociale moi je pense que
c'est la solution c'est la solution avec
en remettant sur la table la question de
l'âge d'une façon peut-être par cette
clause de revoyure je le redis et on
peut avancer comme ça parce que il faut
avancer on peut pas rester dans un pays
bloqué de cette manière là parce qu'on a
un certain nombre d'enjeux à continuer à
avoir l'enjeu écolo
la porte est ouverte ça y est le
président a dit qu'il allait vous
recevoir pour parler de travail
pénibilité pourquoi c'est non pourquoi
la CGT veut pas y aller franchement
alors on n'a pas dit qu'on ne voulait
pas y aller on a dit que si on y allait
d'abord c'est qu'il faudrait discuter
des modalités du retrait ça c'est une
première chose et après bien évidemment
qu'on souhaite voir le président de la
République il me semble que l'Inter
syndical encore avait demandé une
rencontre Emmanuel Macron
j'ai envie de lui dire lol de faire mais
il a l'air de nous dire que voilà une
fois que tout sera fait promulguer on
tourne la page et puis on passe à autre
chose non en fait ça se passe pas comme
ça en vrai ça c'est pas possible c'est
vrai que il rêve de ça parce que je
comprends bien que la séquence qui vient
de se passer pour lui et le gouvernement
est très mauvaise vous l'avez dit il a
perdu énormément de points beaucoup de
discriminer vis-à-vis de la population
une grande majorité de la population
alors oui j'imagine bien que ça serait
facile de dire bon écoutez ça y est
c'est fini tout est passé vous n'ayez
plus rien à voir et on passe à autre
chose non non ça c'est
beaucoup de choses à décanter encore
dernière question pour vous Adrien
Clouet Laurent Berger qui dit à une
colère sourde qui pointe dans le pays le
risque c'est un choc démocratique le
ressentiment peut déboucher sur une
victoire de Marine Le Pen au procès aux
prochaines échéances quand on est un
soumis qu'on se bat contre cette réforme
qu'est-ce qu'on se dit est-ce qu'il est
pas temps peut-être d'essayer de trouver
des voies de passage pour retrouver le
sens du dialogue parce que on voit bien
que politiquement c'est elle qui
engrange
alors d'abord on le voit pas parce que
dans les élections partielles c'est pas
visible pour l'instant mais en revanche
dans l'Ariège c'était une paire de
gauche mais on voit que dans les
sondages
le Ren dépose mon tour dans l'Ariège ni
dans les autres ils ont même perdu un
siège dans les partiels donc moi je
reste très dubitatif sur la politique
avec Ifop mais en laissant ça de côté la
question de la démocratie elle est posée
maintenant c'est à dire vous avez ce
qu'on dit depuis le début une infime
minorité qui veut s'imposer à une grande
majorité comment on règle ce conflit là
quand Morex se confie par des modalités
par des modalités
la démocratie donc c'est vous êtes en
train de dire qu'on n'est pas en
démocratie là aujourd'hui ah bah sur
cette décision non je pense que c'est
pas démocratique si vous pouvez pas le
dire ça la démocratie
c'est une procédure c'est ce que vous
dites démocratie c'est une procédure dès
lors que c'est écrit dans un texte et
qui a une procédure qui le couvre c'est
légitime et parce que c'est légal et ben
moi je pense que c'est pas parce que
c'est légal que c'est légitime la
démocratie c'est le fait de faire
concorder la légalité
parce qu'on a un canal de l'égalité qui
ne correspond pas à des aspirations bah
faut trouver un moyen d'en sortir un
homme son état une bonne élections on
aura les
institutionnel ça vous regarde en direct
évidemment émission spéciale pour
essayer de décortiquer et d'analyser
cette décision et ses conséquences merci
beaucoup on va s'arrêter là et le débat
évidemment continue merci d'être venu
sur le plateau delcp vous restez avec
moi Anne-Sophie dans une dizaine de
minutes toupie les parties pris de nos
affranchis vous les voyez sont en forme
ce soir le rip version Nicole Ferroni ce
sera dans sa carte blanche à la fin de
cette émission la LDH version Yanis
roder la Ligue des droits de l'homme est
dans le collimateur du gouvernement et
puis quatre députés de l'aile gauche de
la macronie dont Barbara popily qui se
retire du groupe Renaissance on verra ça
avec Stéphanie des pierres dans Bourbon
Express mais d'abord Anne-Sophie Yann on
va se plonger dans votre livre ça fait
20 ans que l'actrice Marie Trintignant a
été tuée par Bertrand Cantat à Vilnius
en Lituanie et c'était tout sauf un
accident désir noir chez Flammarion
c'est le récit glaçon je le disais du
omerta où tout le monde savait où tout
le monde
sait tue et où la complaisance de
certains médias et même de certaines
féministes laissent sans voix 20 ans
après regarder c'est dans l'invitation
de Stéphanie Despierre et on en parle à
toutes les deux juste après
si on vous invite à Sofiane c'est parce
que 20 ans après vous revenez sur
l'affaire Bertrand Cantat en juillet
2003 en Lituanie le chanteur du groupe
d'Europe Noir Désir frappe mortellement
sa compagne Marie Trintignant elle
succombe quelques jours plus tard à
l'époque Bertrand Cantat est une star
Marie Trintignant une comédienne fille
d'un monstre sacré du cinéma l'affaire
défraie la chronique le mot féminicide
n'existe pas le mouvement MiTo non plus
Anne-Sophie a nous aide journaliste
culturels au fil de vos ouvrages vous
racontez les turpitudes du monde de la
musique avec des irres vingt ans plus
tard vous ressentez la nécessité de le
redirau et fort et de l'écrire l'amour
de Marie Trintignant n'était pas un
accident l'autopsie ne laisse aucune
place au doute dans des pages glaçantes
vous racontez les dernières heures de
l'actrice et vous fustigez la
complaisance à l'égard de Bertrand
Cantat Bertrand Cantat c'était un homme
de gauche avec des idées pure belle
comme si ça avait quelque chose à voir
avec son crime enfin c'est les violences
conjugales c'est totalement apolitique
mais du coup il a été protégé par son
milieu c'est-à-dire que quand on voit
qu'en 2014 Noël ma mère par exemple le
quelque part le sollicite pour être son
soutien aux élections européennes dans
votre livre vous reprenez d'ailleurs une
tribune hallucinante publiée par des
amis du chanteur 15 jours après le décès
de la comédienne nous restons solidement
convaincus que Bertrand n’est pas fait
pour le rôle qu'on veut lui attribuer
notre compagnon a besoin de retrouver
son honneur au nom de ce qu'il est
réellement vous parlez carrément
d'omerta l'entourage savait que Bertrand
Cantat était violent avec les femmes son
épouse Christina radis ses musiciens en
parle juste après le meurtre mais au
procès plus rien il y a comme un pacte
du silence le chanteur est condamné à 8
ans de prison il sera libéré dès 2007 en
2017 le magazine Les Inrock publie une
longue interview de Bertrand Cantat qui
suscite une énorme polémique peut-on
donner la parole à un meurtrier le
journal El réplique depuis la société a
changé la vague meetou est passée par là
alors Anne-Sophie Yann si le meurtre
avait lieu aujourd'hui tout serait-il
différent
réponse Sofiane évidemment j'ai envie de
dire oui parce qu'en effet on voit que
l'opinion publique sur ces questions est
en train de changer que il y a une prise
de conscience on n'est pas encore à une
un état d'éveil clairement mais en tout
cas ça y est il y a des comportements et
des indulgences qui ne passent plus et
donc on déjà le mot féminicide et est
arrivé donc dans le paysage le champ
lexical social donc ça c'est déjà une
première avancée et mais ça y est
maintenant on voit que ben non des
auteurs de violence conjugales n'ont pas
tous les droits ça veut pas dire que ils
sont pas encore protégés mais en tout
cas enfin il y a un début un
frémissement de mouvement pour s'élever
contre ça un début un frémissement parce
que 20 ans après c'est toujours aussi
difficile d'enquêter sur cette affaire
là on va en parler d'abord il faut qu'on
revienne sur cette longue nuit à Vénus
notez les spectateurs se souviennent
mais pas de tous les détails c'était
tous sauf un accident vous pouvez nous
rappeler prélèvements ce qu'a fait
Bertrand Cantat ce soir du 26 juillet
2003 mais ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est que les faits finalement ils sont
là parce qu'il y a des rapports
d'autopsie il y a des d'abord des
confessions aussi de Bertrand Cantat qui
décrit finalement ce qui s'est passé des
témoignages donc il m'a été finalement
assez facile en retrouvant donc des
documents des témoignages etc de
reconstituer presque minute après minute
exactement ce qui s'est passé donc la
nuit du 27 juillet 2003 à Vilnus à ce
moment-là donc Marie Trintignant est sur
le tournage d'un film qui est réalisé
par sa mère Nadine Trintignant elle est
entourée de d'une partie de sa famille
son frère son fils qui sont qui
travaillent sur le film donc ce qui est
aussi bouleversant c'est qu'elle est
quelque part dans un milieu extrêmement
normalement protégé elle est elle est
chez elle quelque part entourée des
sciences qui est d'ailleurs très souvent
le cas dans dans les violences
conjugales et malgré tout on sent déjà
dans
entourage dans les gens qui travaillent
sur le film ils m'ont tous raconté un
malaise dès le début finalement de
vis-à-vis de Bertrand Cantat qui ne
lâchez pas Marie Trintignant qui était
tout le temps ensemble ils étaient dans
une relation au début totalement
fusionnel alors c'est difficile de
l'extérieur au début de se dire mais
est-ce que c'est malsain est-ce que
c'est pas le malin qui sont pas tout
simplement très très amoureux ce qui est
sûr c'est que elle qui est une femme qui
était extrêmement sociable qui est sur
tous les tournages et elle a fait
énormément de films malgré sa carrière
qui a été coupée fauchée tout le monde
tous les gens avec qui j'ai parlé sont
unanimes elle était toujours avec les
équipes de tournage etc et là tout d'un
coup elle se referme et elle est avec
lui et donc elle reçoit un moment dans
la journée un SMS de son de son mari le
père de cette réforme exactement Samuel
benchetritt avec qui elle vient aussi
d'ailleurs de tourner un film il part de
la promo du justement du film qu'elle
doit assurer et il signe ma petite Janis
parce qu'elle joue dans ce film le sosie
de Janis Joplin
c'est assez anodin comme message et
pourtant Bertrand Cantat ne le supporte
pas il devient fou il n'arrive pas à
lâcher il faut décrirait vraiment
l'ultra violence d'une brute il faut
rappeler aussi qu'elle était cheztive et
petite Marie Trintignant c'était tout
sauf un accident parce que exactement
inouïe et ça il faut le dire et le
redire il y a eu ces coûts et puis il y
a eu ce temps ces 7 heures au cours
desquels elle n'était pas à l'hôpital
mais dans son lit alors qu'elle avait le
nez cassé qu'elle avait des hématomes
partout oui ce qui est ce qui est
fascinant c'est que comment ça se fait
qu'on a pu imaginer un seul instant
qu'elle soit morte par accident ou à la
suite d'une dispute qui a mal tournée
parce que les les faits ils sont là et
ils sont très tangibles 19 coups des
coûts mortels portés au visage avec
d'une violence absolument inouïe en
effet avec il portait des très grosses
bagues des eaux fracassées donc il est
même inconcevable quand on revit la
scène de se dire qu'il avait pas
conscience de la gravité des faits alors
vous faites le portrait preuve à l'appui
d'un homme ultra-violent avec les femmes
bien avant il faut le redire ça aussi
cette nuit de coût contre Marie
Trintignant Bertrand Cantat avait déjà
frappé violemment d'autres femmes et son
clan ses proches savaient et personne
n'a jamais rien dit pourquoi
l'arme la plus redoutable de tous les
auteurs de violences conjugales c'est le
silence donc ça commence toujours par là
le silence d'abord des victimes qui en
effet se sont tues l'ont protégé la
première des victimes c'est sa femme
Christine Arabie qui malgré le fait
d'avoir été quand même abandonné pour
Marie Trintignant vole à son secours
immédiatement à Vilnus pour le défendre
qui va jouer un rôle très important en
procès aliment absolument et c'est au
départ d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'ils ont tous leur première
instinct c'est ils ont une première
version de on comprend que ça s'est déjà
produit que c'est pas la première fois
elle-même le dit à différentes personnes
à différents moments de différentes
manières que elle-même a été victime de
violence qu'elle n'est pas pas seul qui
la frappé les quatre femmes qu'il a aimé
donc à ce moment-là donc ça veut dire
marie-traintignant elle plus deux autres
des membres du groupe aussi font
certaines allusions dans ce sens et le
jour où Marie Trintignant meurt le
premier août donc quelques jours plus
tard elle et que là tout d'un coup
l'affaire devient un homicide finalement
et donc il y a un vrai risque pour
Bertrand Cantat de passer des années et
en prison exactement 15 là tout le monde
va changer de version et ça va vraiment
participer à une décision collective de
mentir pour le protéger ce qui frappe
c'est que cette omertale dure encore
vous raconter très bien que la plupart
des proches du chanteur préfèrent vous
parler de façon anonyme mais comme on a
peu de temps je voudrais que vous me
parliez de la complaisance et même de
l'indulgence des médias regardez comment
à l'époque en 2003 par image titré sur
la mort de Marie Trintignant de une
victime de la passion elle a été battue
à mort par le chanteur de Noir Désir il
s'aimait à la folie c'est extrêmement
choquant avec le recul cette une oui
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'ils
responsable il s'aimait donc elle est
morte quelque part et il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont les beaucoup de mots
qu'il ne devraient absolument pas
figurer dans ce titre passion déjà c'est
pas on ne tue pas par passion le on ne
fera pas une femme par amour c'est ça a
été dit déjà à l'époque par Valérie
thorardian dans elle et je crois que
c'est des mots très très justes et il
faut jamais les oublier c'est pas de
l'amour l'amour c'est pas ça c'est pas
massacrer une femme à coup de poing et
donc il y a eu cette confusion c'est
quoi cette confusion à votre avis c'est
l'époque où il y a une faute morale tout
simplement qu'il faut dire je pense que
même avec le recul du temps il y a un
problème et c'est là où cette affaire
elle est très intéressante c'est qu'elle
appuie exactement sur nos mauvaises
conceptions et sur le les dangers dans
notre société sur ces affaires là c'est
à dire que clairement d'abord le la
première réaction c'est de d'en faire un
geste romantique comme si voilà on tue
comme si on tuait par amour qu'un homme
qui aime une femme passionnément était
pouvait la tuer et en effet on voit
qu'il des complaisance même à l'époque
presque juridique c'est-à-dire qu'on a
une peine moins importante si on tue une
femme qu'on aime que si on tue pas son
patron à coup de poing par exemple des
choses comme ça donc c'est assez
tangible finalement mais est-ce que
c'est dans notre représentation je sais
pas latine de l'amour que on se dit un
homme qui aime tellement sa femme et
capable de la tuer il y a des chansons
de Johnny Hallyday Requiem justement
pour un fou qui raconte exactement la
même chose c'est un des plus grands
tubes du chanteur donc ça montre quelque
part que en nous on a déjà cette
mauvaise conception qu'il faut vraiment
déconstruire et détricoter quatre ans de
prison au lieu des 8 libération
conditionnelle vous écrivez après la Une
des Inrock qui a énormément choqué au
moment où on les revoit là quand tu es
en son nom et bien le chanteur revient
avec un nouvel album et une tournée de
concert vous écrivez que la presse de
gauche a une part de responsabilité dans
la réhabilitation de Quentin à l'époque
c'était quoi c'était l'altermondialisme
du côté
du du camp du Bien c'est ça contre la
droite et les puissants oui parce que
c'est Bertrand Cantat lui-même et ses
proches qui ont dès le début des Vilus
en 2003 placer l'affaire sur un terrain
politique donc c'est pas quelque chose
qui a été créé de toutes pièces ou qui
est subjectif c'est que eux-mêmes ce
sont présentés comme donc des icônes de
gauche altermondialiste qui ont des
combats juste contre le clan Trintignant
parisien bourgeois riche avec un plus
voilà quelque chose un petit peu de
nauséabond et pour ça aussi que même les
féministes n'ont pas parlé Caroline de
Haas d'oser le féminisme n'a pas voulu
elle a jamais voulu parler elle sait
jamais exprimée sur l'affaire alors que
pourtant les féminiciens sont censés
être un de ces combats les plus
importants et tweet toute la journée sur
les féminicides et sur cette affaire en
particulier elle se tait malgré mes
relances malgré mes tentatives etc elle
a jamais voulu s'exprimer ce qui m'a
d'ailleurs énormément j'étais la
première surprise moi je pensais qu'au
contraire elle aurait des choses très
intéressantes à dire une forme de aussi
peut-être je sais pas de ça serait
intéressant de les entendre dire
justement je me suis trompé j'ai trop
longtemps été silencieux sur ces
questions et pour terminer vous parlez
d'une situation paradoxale depuis Miou
on condamne le harcèlement sexuel un
homme faisant un commentaire déplacé à
une femme par SMS peut être viré mais un
homme frappant des femmes parfois à mort
doit à tout prix conserver tous ces
privilèges vous trouvez vraiment qu'il y
a deux poids de mesure complètement
c'est à dire que c'est
la vague me too qui était extrêmement
importantes et parce que justement elle
montrait la masse ce qui était le de
victimes le nombre de victimes de
violences sexuelles le prolongement
logique ça aurait été une deuxième vague
celle contre les violences conjugales
parce que les violences conjugales elles
sont extrêmement banales une femme qui
meurt tous les trois jours sous les
coups de son compagnon c'est énorme ça
veut dire que tous autour de nous on en
connaît que tous autour de nous dans nos
amis parce que c'est pas du tout lié à
ni un lieu géographique un milieu social
on connaît tous des femmes qui sont
frappées et quelque part on est complice
on est tous complices un petit peu et
sur le même plan toutes les formes de
violence et malheureusement ou
d'agressions sexuelles parce que il
faudrait qu'il y ait une dénonciation
pour contre les violences conjugales
merci beaucoup Anne-Sophie Yann Le Point
cette semaine comment ne pas le le
nommer avec en une Emmanuel Seigner et
Samantha guenner sur l'affaire Polanski
sa prolonge d'une certaine façon un peu
vos réflexions et votre enquête désirent
noir c'est-à-dire chez Flammarion vous
restez avec moi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris vous vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite les amis c'est à
VOUS l'historien Yanis roder de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès l'humoriste Nicole
Ferroni pour sa carte blanche bienvenue
à tous les deux installez-vous on va
commencer comme chaque soir par le
bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est raconté ce soir par
Stéphanie Despierre bonsoir Stéphanie
Myriam alors ce soir je vous raconte
l'histoire de quatre députés poils à
gratter de la majorité qui viennent
d'annoncer qu'elles ne sont plus membres
du groupe Renaissance à la veille de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel sur
les retraites le symbole n'est pas très
bon pour le camp présidentiel alors la
plus connue c'est barbara Pompili
l'ancienne ministre de l'écologie
d'Emmanuel Macron autour d'elle il y a
des visages beaucoup moins connus
Mireille clapot député de la Drôme
c'était la Dupont du Maine-et-Loire
Cécile relac du Val d'Oise alors elles
ont en commun justement d'être tout
issus de la gauche écologiste elles
appartiennent au parti en commun fondées
par barbara Pompili et elle menaçait de
ne pas voter la réforme des retraites
cet hiver mais c'est la première fois
qu'elles prennent aussi clairement leur
distance avec le groupe majoritaire tout
en minimisant leur décision barbara
Pompili qu'est-ce qui ne vous convient
plus à Renaissance en fait ce que nous
voulons faire avec les députés dans
commun c'est clarifier la situation on
est dans une situation qui était un
petit peu compliqué à comprendre pour
les gens nous avons décidé de construire
un parti qui s'appelle en commun qui
fait partie de la majorité mais qui se
distingue de renaissance nous n'avons
jamais voulu adhérer au parti
Renaissance on voulait laisser passer le
passage des retraites à l'Assemblée pour
éviter les confusions et donc tout
naturellement nous avons décidé de
clarifier en nous mettant en apparenté
pour bien signifier que nous sommes dans
la majorité mais que nous n'appartenons
pas à se partir Renaissance nous avons
notre propre partie et notre propre
sensibilité que nous souhaitons exprimer
est-ce que ce ne serait pas plus clair
et plus compréhensible pour les Français
que vous quittiez le groupe ce qui
serait plus compréhensible c'est qu'on
est un groupe qui correspond à notre
partie mais ça ne vous a pas échappé que
nous sommes quatre députés c'est un peu
juste pour faire un groupe aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale et je ne souhaite
pas que les seuils soient baissés
et oui c'est un peu juste pour créer un
groupe il faut être au moins 15 députés
et là Myriam on en est loin alors
quelles conséquences politiques à ce
vrai faux départ alors des conséquences
plutôt minimes parce que les quatre
députés restent apparentés en clair
c'est un semi divorce elles ont les
avantages d'appartenir à un groupe
politique mais sans les inconvénients ce
qu'il faut souligner en revanche c'est
que pour la première fois ou presque
barbara Pompili et les chefs du groupe
Renaissance sont parfaitement d'accord
leur message est clair circulez il n'y a
rien à voir
donc en réalité ça ne change rien à
notre fonctionnement de groupe les
députés barbara Pompili Cécile RIAC etc
continueront à voir leur responsabilité
leur voix au sein du groupe
parlementaire de la majorité
présidentielle et en réalité c'est
surtout effectivement une logique de
mouvement politique qu'il faut pouvoir
respecter ces quatre députés ont été
très critiques pendant la réforme des
retraites ça n'a vraiment rien à voir
elles ont pas été très critiques elles
ont fait valoir leurs droits
parlementaire leur liberté parlementaire
alors offre à Renaissance certains
s'interrogent quand même sur le timing
de cette décision alors que tout le
monde attend le verdict des sages sur la
réforme des retraites depuis plusieurs
mois on sent bien que barbara Pompili
n'est plus très à l'aise dans ce camp
présidentiel d'autres députés glissent
aussi que ce changement intervient deux
jours après la nomination d'un nouveau
directeur à la Commission nationale du
débat public postent convoité par
l'ancienne ministre de l'écologie un
ministre toujours en poste lui fait ce
constat barbara Pompili est toujours en
marge et puis en janvier quand la député
de la Somme avait annoncé qu'elle
envisageait de ne pas voter la réforme
des retraites un de ses collègues
soupirait méchamment elle ne sait plus
quoi faire pour exister depuis qu'elle
n'est plus ministre voilà c'est dit
merci beaucoup Stéphanie sta comme ça
qu'on fronde en macronie c'est loin loin
ce qui se passait au Parti socialiste
Yanis on passe à la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme vous voulez revenir sur toutes
ces interrogations ces prises de
position autour de la LDH alors hier
c'était ta première ministre qui s'est
interrogée sur les positions de cette
association à la suite du ministre
Darmanin qui avait déclaré que la
subvention donnée à l'état à la LDH
méritait d'être regardé qu'est-ce qui se
passe quelle mouche a piqué le
gouvernement certaines prises de
position de la LDH ne sont pas passés
inaperçues au gouvernement le point de
départ de cette affaire est lié à un
recours en référé liberté par le fait
par LDH contre l'arrêté pris par la
préfète des Deux-Sèvres prévoyant
l'interdiction d'armes par destination
c'est à dire de tout qui peut servir
d'armes dans le cadre des manifestations
de sainte Soline contre les méga
bassines recours rejetés d'ailleurs par
la justice rappelons néanmoins que le 29
octobre 2022 les précédents
affrontements à saint-sauline avaient
fait 120 blessés parmi les manifestants
les forces de l'ordre alors apparemment
c'est les prises de position de la LDH
en général qui questionnent le
gouvernement ça va un petit peu au-delà
de sainte Soline oui tout à fait par
exemple le fait qu'elle dénonce avec
virulence l'attitude de la police si je
vis pour cela de regarder son site
internet on y parle de politique brutale
du gouvernement de situation
particulièrement alarmantes pour la
démocratie ou encore d'opérations de
maintien de l'ordre de grande ampleur
violente et totalement disproportionnée
notons que rien n'est dit sur les
violences des groupes d'ultra gauche à
Sainte Soline ou dans les cortèges des
manifestations contre la femme de la
retraite bon alors effectivement le ton
n'est pas très modéré à la LDH ces
derniers temps non Myriam c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire ça ne peut qu'agacer
le ministre de l'Intérieur et la même
choqué une autre organisation connue
pour son engagement pour les droits de
l'homme la lycra la Ligue internationale
de lutte le racisme mais l'antisémitisme
laquelle parle d'un agenda partisan et
dénonce la lecture partiale des
événements par la LDH et l'affaire ne
s'arrête pas là ah non parce que Gérald
Darmanin franchit un pas en posant la
question des financements publics perçus
par une organisation qui se réclame des
droits de l'homme et la réaction ne
s'est pas fait attendre puisque le
journal l'Humanité a lancé un texte de
défense de la LDH signé par l'ensemble
de la gauche et vous alors Yanis redder
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je pense
que c'est quand même la beauté de la
démocratie que les associations
critiquent soient financièrement
soutenues ce qui n'empêche pas de
s'interroger sur les discours d'une
association qui s'abrite beaucoup
aujourd'hui derrière un glorieux passé
dréfusard ce qui mérite d'être
questionné selon moi c'est l'utilisation
systématique par la LDH de l'argument de
la liberté face aux décisions de l'État
à Sainte-Souline bien sûr mais c'est
aussi l'argument de la liberté qui est
mis en avant par la LDH quand elle
proteste contre la loi de 2010 contre le
nikab vous savez ce qui dissimule le
visage des femmes c'est encore cet
argument la liberté que qui est mis en
avant quand la LDH critique la
dissolution du CCIF ou l'expulsion de
l'imam ixusen alors pour l'association
que cela fasse le jeu de groupe violent
ou le jeu des islamistes n'importe pas
elle ne transige pas avec la liberté
quitte à faire le jeu des ennemis de
cette même liberté merci beaucoup en
voilà un parti pris un mot de réaction
un peu plus de temps c'est parti Nicole
Ferroni ce soir vous êtes suspendu à
cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel de demain tout à fait et
pas seulement de savoir voilà si les
articles de la réforme de la de des
retraites pardon vont être heureux ok
mais aussi pour savoir si le fameux
compte va nous dire OUI OUI au sujet du
Rip alors le rip RIP qu'est-ce que c'est
donc c'est un acronyme qui signifie
référendum d'initiative partagée mais
qui pourrait aussi vouloir dire
ressuscite immédiatement Parlement
puisque comme vous le savez les députés
de notre Parlement n'ont pas pu débattre
du fameux article 7 celui sur le report
de l'âge légal de départ en retraite à
64 ans et donc certains des
parlementaires ont décidé de ressusciter
ce sujet considéré comme enterré
justement en faisant une première
demande de RIP et une deuxième demande
de RIP in extremis donc autrement dit ce
référendum d'initiative partagé vous
savez c'est un peu comme ceux ces textos
qu'on envoie à trois heures du matin à
son ex
avec beaucoup d'alcool et très peu de
dignité pour le dire qu'on l'aime encore
et qu'on aime bien que
vous envoyez pas ce genre de texto en
tout cas je vous dis juste voilà voilà
mais vous savez c'est le truc de la
dernière chance exactement sauf que si
un texto ça peut s'envoyer n'importe
comment ce n'est pas le cas du Rip qui
lui pour être lancé doit répondre
vraiment à des conditions qui sont très
strictes pour être enclenché en effet
premièrement un il doit être porté par
au moins 20 % des parlementaires donc
c'est à dire 185 députés sénateurs sur
les 925 ça c'est bon ça c'est fait pour
le premier riz deuxièmement le rythme
dans le titre recevoir l'accord du
Conseil constitutionnel et justement
c'est une des réponses qu'on attend
demain et troisième condition c'est la
plus dure le rip doit ensuite être
soutenu par plus de 10% de l'électorat
français c'est-à-dire plus de 4,8
millions d'électeurs c'est énorme et
c'est ce qui fait qu'à ce jour aucun
référendum d'initiative partagé n'est
plus aboutir et rien que d'y penser on
se dit que c'est déprimant alors je sais
que vous allez me dire écoutez dans ce
cas-là Nicole ni pensez pas puisque de
toute façon le Conseil constitutionnel
n'a pas donné son aval en plus pour le
deuxième riz pour attendre jusqu'au mois
de mai et oui mais non ça je vous
déconseille de faire ça c'est à dire
d'attendre la réponse de l'un pour
préparer l'autre parce que il faut bien
se rendre compte que s'il y a équipes à
4,8 millions avec 4,8 millions de
personnes c'est exactement comme prendre
un TGV avec des enfants c'est à dire
c'est pas au moment du départ que d'un
coup on s'y prépare non parce que quand
vous partez en TGV avec des enfants et
bien sûr il vous pensez en amont à
prendre la compote prendre le doudou et
ben pour le rip c'est pareil c'est à
dire qu'il faut pas attendre son
lancement pour avoir les choses en main
et quand je dis des choses je parle
évidemment carte électorale ou une carte
d'identité et de la patience parce que
le rip est un voyage très long et très
compliqué et ça c'est pas moi qui le dis
c'est qui c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel lui-même qui qui
qualifie la procédure je cite de
dissuasive alors heureusement que moi
j'ai déjà signé un rite par le passé je
peux vous donner des petites astuces
pour pour éviter les problèmes première
astuce d'abord soyez concentré parce que
précédent RIP il y a plus de 18000
personnes qui ont vu leur signature
invalidée parce qu'elles avaient mal
tapé le numéro de leur carte d'identité
donc attention on est hop hop quand on
signe le riz trip deuxième conseil
dispatchez-vous sur les horaires je vous
le rappelle vous avez 9 mois pour donner
votre soutien or si vous mettez à 4,8
millions de personnes en même temps le
site va planter donc par exemple quand
l'un écoute du rap lost in the RIP et
ensuite vous inversez et enfin dernier
conseil comme il arrive que le site ne
fonctionne pas avec certains navigateurs
et là c'est pas que c'est encore pas moi
qui le dit c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel lui-même si votre
voisine ne veut pas vous prêter son ordi
à cause vous savez de l'embrouille que
vous avez eu au moment de l'assemblée
générale pour le syndic de pro c'est pas
grave sachez que vous pouvez signer le
référendum d'initiative partagé en
version papier dans la mairie de la
commune la plus peuplée de votre canton
et au prix de ces efforts peut-être que
votre RIP deviendra un reprip pourra oh
magnifique chut le rythme d'emploi
franchement et ben une bonne chronique
de Nicole Ferroni j'ai tout compris et
encore quelques petits obstacles même si
ils ont presque 5 millions c'est vrai on
verra ça demain d'ailleurs dans cette
émission puisque on aura une émission
spéciale consacrée à cette décision
attendue à 17h40 du Conseil des Sages le
Conseil constitutionnel merci beaucoup
Anne-Sophie Yann d'être venu sur le
plateau LCP merci les affranchis à lire
chez Flammarion désir noir
la mort de Marie Trintignant n'était pas
un accident très belle soirée
documentaire qui commence maintenant
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain même
les mandats
[Musique]